she came out I'm sorry just you know one
day you're swimming in the pool and the
next day it's all G but
yeah Islam net is raising funds to
establish a mid and Community Center in
Norway and they urgently need your
support this donation will be a for you
because every person that comes a step
closer to Allah through your donation
you want sh be reing the click the link
and donate what you
Canam brothers and sisters and dear
friends Allah subhana Works in amazing
ways subh brother and sisters and that's
what Allah says in the Quran do not ever
think Allah is unaware of what the evil
doers are doing he only delays them for
a day where their eyes will look in
horror and there's a verse in the Quan
Allah says we sent a small Calamity to
divert you from a bigger Calamity cuz
Allah is the most merciful this
douchebag this absolute scum of scum
scums James Woods yes I don't know
anything about him I some kind of actor
whatever is for that matter he tweeted
to this when the whole God of stream was
happening no ceasefire no compromise no
forgiveness kill them
all can you imagine can you
imagine kill them all now you bastard
you scumbag now his house was caught in
the whole Wildfire we don't wish this on
anybody anyone for this matter but
there's a point to be made here yes that
dirt bag like you and look at this
interview of Sky News and when they
listening to him and the woman's the
interview is going to be in tears you
know such
heartfelt and usually it will be
heartfelt anybody watching this will be
like you know what of course this is
somethingone losing the house you know
he was building for it for three years
we're going to watch it in a minute now
we're going to react to in and he lost
all that in three months and he's
talking about this young girl 8 years
old who gave her piggy bank I mean
innocent child you know towards the new
house or whatever look at their reaction
man and he's crying cuz he lost a
property nobody died he lost his
property but the same man under the same
breath the same reporter if it's a
Palestinian child who massacred they
call it a young
girl it's not even they could see it's a
child this is how they have dehumanized
Palestinians watch this for yourself
it's sickening it's sickening but let me
tell you something yeah no one has
remorse for you my friend no one may
Allah increase you in punishment may
Allah increase you in punishment may you
cry more may you suffer more just the
way you have made it or been you know
advocate of the Israelis massacring the
genocide that's going on in Palestine
and you are here saying kill them all no
ceasefire no compromise no forgiveness
here's a video guys watch it for
yourself and I'm just going to end on
this video I'm not going to say nothing
else I'm not going to come back to say
nothing watch it for yourself inshah how
this flipping weasel of a man how Allah
made him crumble to his knees this is
just this life if only you know what's
waiting for you to hear after if you
don't change your ways yes and you think
God is on your
side anyways enjoy this video and just
watch the how they dehumanize
Palestinians and look at their attitude
for a old grumpy PR genocidal Maniac man
who doesn't mind the masculine of
innocent men when children babies blown
into pieces is crying like a flipping
about his house being on
fire asalam alikum
enjoy the
video I I posted this on X but but Sarah
was on with her 8-year-old niece last
night she came out I'm sorry just you
know one day you're swim in the pool and
the next day it's all gone but uh she
came out with her little yeti piggy
bank for us to rebuild our
house
oh oh my gosh James Woods I I we all
hope that you will be able to rebuild
your house maybe starting with that
little yeti piggy bank and we're just
glad that you're okay and your wife is
okay have your
lives yeah no I mean this is real and
it's raw I thought I would be stronger
than this you don't you are you know
what it's strength is not measured by
whether you know you hold in crying or
not strength is what you are doing now
and helping your neighbors and the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam said
whoever builds a Masjid for the sake of
Allah subhana taala Allah will build for
him a similar house in jenah on that day
where Allah subhana tells us that our
books will be given and every little at
and weight of Good Deed you've done will
be there and imagine you see a mountain
and you're like what a lucky person
which righteous person and Allah says
this is for you for me yes what did I do
you allow people to pray you built a
Masid I never had the money to build a
Masid oh Allah you helped you gave
towards it and Allah gives you the
reward of as if you built it donate now
guys and do not delay and share the
video for extra reward
[Music]